what does up or out even mean what is
this even supposed to mean what this
really boils down to is that in the end
throughout your career in Consulting you
get either designated either you get
promoted to the next level every other
year or so or at some point if you are
not getting promoted you will be asked
to leave the firm so pretty much your
work contract will be terminated so but
why do consulting firms do this what is
their rationale for doing that well they
want to keep the pyramid in the
organization and they want to make sure
that they create a system where the very
best get to the top and the people who
maybe do not perform to these highest
levels that they expect would at some
point leave the organization